members of Syracuse Theta Tau fraternity
are apologizing for an offensive video
that triggered protests on campus and
led to the frats suspension a roughly
six minute video shows what appears to
be fraternity members performing skits
using racist sexist and other crude
language the chapter apologized
overnight in a letter saying quote our
house is not and has never been a place
for hate Adriana Diaz is outside the
suspended fraternities house in Syracuse
Adriana good morning good morning
Syracuse University police are now
investigating the video which is hard to
watch a student newspaper the daily
Orange discovered it on a secret
Facebook page for fraternity brothers
the nude and crude video shows what
appears to be faded out brothers joking
about the Holocaust and using racist
slurs
the chapter apologized overnight in a
lengthy letter saying it's with profound
embarrassment and disappointment in
ourselves that we find our fraternity in
this situation but they say the frat is
not a hate group or a house full of
bigots instead the letter says the video
recorded last month shows a satirical
sketch performed by fraternity pledges
intended to roast active brothers it
says the young men were playing
characters and do not hold the views
they expressed in the video the national
fraternities top officials said in a
Facebook post Thursday the actions of
these individuals are truly disgraceful
and we will take appropriate action
based on the findings of the
investigation students have marched
across campus demanding the university
hold the fraternity brothers accountable
Syracuse president Kent syverud said a
comprehensive review of the Theta Tau
chapter is now underway he also promised
a series of reforms including diversity
training for all members of the Greek
system and a closer look at the role of
Dean's and other university leaders the
first time I view good is sick to my
stomach
dolan ivanovich a Syracuse senior vice
president says campus police have
interviewed all 48 members of Ada tau
for possible violations like hazing and
abusive language it's shocking it's
appalling his activity that is against
all of our community standards and
values that's why we immediately
suspended this fraternity and will
conduct a very thorough review and
analysis penalties could range from
suspension to expulsion for the
fraternity brothers and according to the
daily Orange this chapter here is the
fourth fraternity to be suspended by the
school this academic year the other
three were for hazing gail adriana thank
you so much i just don't know what it's
gonna take for people to realize this
isn't funny no I don't think it does any
good to expel them but I think there has
talked about racial bias training
sensitivity training even as a joke it
just is not fun it's not funny and I
think the president of Syracuse
University should sit down with them and
talk to them because even if they were
expelled
they're gonna go out into society yeah
and so there has to be kind of a alert
experience here in a discussion about it
that's exactly the right point it's not
just what's already in their hearts
returnees when they defend themselves
they say they need these kinds of events
among brothers to build up a brotherhood
around common experience so look at
what's at the heart of this common
experience it is hatred and bigotry so
you're sending them out in the world
armed with that kind of hate yeah